Find the line of
best fit, or mark
that there is no
linear correlation.
So let's see, we have
a bunch of data points,
and we want to find a
line that at least shows
the trend in the data.
And this one seems
a little difficult
because if we ignore these
three points down here,
maybe we could do a line that
looks something like this.
It seems like it kind of
approximates this trend,
although this doesn't
seem like a great trend.
And if we ignored these
two points right over,
we could do something like
maybe something like that.
But we can't just
ignore points like that.
So I would say that
there's actually
no good line of best fit here.
So let me check my answer.
Let's try a couple
more of these.
Find the line of best-- well,
this feels very similar.
It really feels like there's
no-- I mean, I could do that,
but I'm ignoring
these two points.
I could do something
like that, then
I'd be ignoring these points.
So I'd also say no good
best fit line exists.
So let's try one more.
So here it looks like there's
very clearly this trend.
And I could try to fit it a
little bit better than it's
fit right now.
So it feels like something
like that fits this trend line
quite well.
I could maybe drop this
down a little bit, something
like that.
Let's check my answer.
A good best fit line exists.
Let me check my answer.
We got it right.